[Music]
sunday in philadelphia
sunday how are we doing i'm amazing how
you guys doing
amazing as well what can we do to help
well i'm really calling because i've
been with my
fiance for a long while now we've been
together for about 10 years
it's finally taken me 10 years to open
up
and say okay i'm ready i'm ready to put
our money together i'm ready to
to go in hard on this and i mean finally
i'm a fiance so now i feel pretty safe
but um with that being said
i'm i'm scared that he's not going to
follow through i listen to dave ramsey
all the time
he listened to it but he doesn't always
go in what should i do
yes sunday there's a lot here i was
about to say something then i thought
i'm not going to say anything and let
anthony and he just turned and looked
directly at me
so you should be scared
okay yes
10 years that's a decade right
yes and suddenly you you feel like
you're going to feel safe because you
got a ring on your finger after
a decade right yes
and three presidents ago how about that
so thank you a long time ago
and it felt good for a few days you got
that ring finally
and then your your consciousness kicked
back in
your frontal lobe came back online and
you thought
oh man this is the same guy that either
i
or he or we have not felt in sync with
for a decade enough to get married
right so you should your body's alarm
systems are going off and they should be
right is that fair yeah
am i telling you anything that you don't
already know
yes no i don't know
sunday i'm just telling you the truth i
i'm gonna i'm gonna turn over anthony
here
you're not in a position to be joining
money up together right now
you're not safe until you are married
you're not safe until you've sat down
and had full conversations and if you
have some priorities
and your priorities right now according
to your language is being
safe that's baseline for a marriage
and after a decade with somebody if you
don't feel safe you guys need to have
different conversations
you need to be having deeper
conversations probably at this point
with a with a therapist with a pastor in
your community
that you can be open and honest with
because you're going in hedging your
bets
on a marriage and it's not going to work
and you should not not
not be joining money with a 10 year
boyfriend
who you know is not all into
how long have you been engaged sunday
just about a year when when you are
getting married
well can i just blame it on the pandemic
no
no no no you go get married at the
courthouse no sunday now you know you
can't come in here and talk with ao and
jd like that
i'm saying maybe dave but not with us so
what are y'all getting married
what's the date we know it's this year
what's the day oh my god i don't have a
game i'll tell you what it is all right
20 32.
what's another what's another 10 years
why not
no i'm gonna do better sunday listen
um you already know you don't need to be
combining your
your finances with a potential husband
okay um you're not you're not in a safe
place but i do know
ladies that is an emotion emotional
security is very important and i
understand that
but a ring on your finger as
a fiance is not the emotional security
all right
so what i'm telling you is set the date
go to the courthouse this weekend
go to the courthouse tomorrow go ahead
and become husband and wife
and together y'all work a game plan but
until then
until you all are legally married
and i don't know about pennsylvania but
y'all may be already
uh pretty much married because of common
law
and common law um but i mean i'm talking
about within the eyesight of
god i mean that's just my faith in the
christian faith i want y'all to go ahead
and get legally married and have a plan
together stop do y'all live together
yes yeah so you're already giving him
wife benefits and
and he can leave you tomorrow
okay and so for me right now what you
need to do is say you know what babe
let's go get married let's do this
we've been together for 10 years do you
all have kids together
yes we have a daughter yeah so i don't
know what what we're playing on
okay uh wha wha what's going on here
sunday you have kids together
okay so you're already doing husband and
wife things you bout to combine your
money you live in the same place you're
paying all the bills together
just go ahead and get married don't
blame it on covet don't blame it on no
one else
and then once kobe gets over then yeah
you can have a huge celebration
but i firmly do believe that if you do
it in a healthy and the right way
blessings follow that the security that
you desire the emotional security
that you desire the blessings that you
desire will come
once you just get married you're already
doing
everything
right go get married but i'll but i'll
add this i want to add this if
you only want to get married when you
feel safe
you have your answer and you know that
right
right who's who's the reason we're being
held up here
[Laughter]
look at here girl it's been 10 years
baby what are we going to do so we could
tell
it's on both of them right but if you go
get married what i'm saying here is if
if sunday if you go get married tomorrow
and and you're unable to have hard
conversations
with someone you've been with for a
decade that you have a child with
that's not just gonna solve itself on
monday right
right i'm i'm confused to why it sounds
like
they're both scared of commitment
because they're already doing every
everything else so it sounds like i am
scared to
legally say this is the rest of my life
because we're already doing everything
and what i want to get to is why are you
still scared after 10 years that's what
i
yes that's yes yes so sunday you got to
address those hard hard questions yeah
and if you come to a place where you say
i'm he's my guy
you like can't you said you're already
doing it you're already there
then you come come back we're going to
give you ramsey plus you and him
your new husband you're going to go
through it together you're going to
learn these lessons together you're
going to dream
and create a vision together it's never
too late to start then after 10 years
of running in place then you're going to
be ready to rock and roll